the most effective strategies for
dealing with depression and anxiety
are the ones that deal with the reasons
why we feel so bad in the first place
we need to stop asking what's wrong with
you and start asking
what happened to you if you think life
is about money
and status and showing off you're gonna
feel like [ __ ] it's not like i'm
explaining quantum physics right and
we've all had that experience where you
crave a consumer object
you build up to it you get it you get
home and you just feel flat
is it's not the trauma that destroys you
it's the shame about the trauma
and giving people ways to release that
shame
is an antidepressant god
change is really possible
today we have a real treat for you
this guest today johan hari is one of my
all-time favorite ever podcast guests
ever and i'm not saying that to blow
smoke up his ass when i had the
conversation with him and when i started
reading his books many years ago
i can quite honestly say that no book
i've ever read in my life has had more
of a positive impact
a more transformative impact on the
topics that matter most to my
fulfillment and happiness
than the work that johann has done he is
a comedian on one hand
he's an incredible storyteller he spends
a decade writing his book so you know
the information he's going to share with
you today
is both profound it is evidence-backed
and it is compelling
true important and everything that our
society at this point in time
needs to hear this could well be the
most important podcast i've ever
recorded
if you asked me if there was one podcast
that i wish the world's
got to hear it's definitely this one
above all of the other podcasts i've
ever recorded this is the conversation
so without further ado i'm stephen
bartlett and this is the dire ceo
i hope nobody's listening but if you are
then please keep this to yourself
[Music]
johan it's uh it's a real pleasure to
have you back on the podcast you are one
of my all-time
favorite guests top three i don't know
the order but you're definitely up there
these other two i don't actually
and not just because of the conversation
we had but because you changed my
fundamental beliefs
around depression mental health
the importance of human connection and
everything in between
and that had a really fundamental
positive impact on my life
it's also you feature heavily in my book
i talk about you on this podcast all the
time
so you know the amount of times i've
plugged so really what i brought you
here today was to get the royalties from
all the friends no but no but i do i
talk about this podcast all the time so
give you an old bag of crisps please
that's all you're getting that's why i
wanted to get in the podcast because
you know you changed my life and i'm not
saying that's no smoke up your ass i
genuinely mean that
with your book lost connections so the
first question i have is like completely
off track but
i've just finished writing my book
published it's all great and everything
you're
you're onto your third fourth book now
yeah yeah talk to me about why you like
writing books what is it about writing
books
why are you doing that oh for me
i write books because there's a question
i want to answer for myself that i don't
know the answer to at the start
so we'd lost connections i wanted to
there would
for me there's always a core mystery
that i want to understand right so we've
lost connections to core mystery was two
really simple things when i
when the book came out i was 40. uh all
throughout my lifetime depression and
anxiety have increased in britain
the us crossed the world i wanted to
understand why right why is it that with
each year that passes
more and more of us are finding it
harder to get through the day i wanted
to understand it for a personal reason
which is that i had been really
depressed myself i had done
everything i was told to do by my
doctors and i remained depressed
or chasing the screen my but before that
um i had a kind of core question which
was
you know we had a lot of addiction in my
family one of my earliest memories is of
trying to wake up one of my relatives
and not being able to
um and i wanted to understand what
causes addiction
and what can we actually do about it i
want to understand a personal level but
also
at a social level what we could do about
it so for me
i always start with a core question um
so a book i'm been working on for the
last 10 years that i'm sort of writing
at the moment about
um something i have to be careful what i
say about a series of crimes that have
been happening in las vegas
for me there's always a core question a
mystery
and then i'm like okay i want to take
the reader on a journey
as i try to unsolve this mystery i tried
to solve this mystery for myself right
so um all of my books are
long journeys where i you know for both
books i traveled more than 30 000 miles
went to a crazy mixture of people and
for me the best journeys
are not where you find yourself everyone
goes are you on a journey to find
yourself to me the best journey is where
you find other people
right so i think about the crazy mixture
of people that i've got to know for
these books
who i love who are still you know
important people to me from you know
for the addiction book i think about
chino hardin who's a
trans crack dealer in brooklyn who's one
of the smartest people i've ever met
uh rosalia retta a hitman of the
deadliest mexican drug cartel
he's unfortunately not one of the
smartest people i've ever met but uh you
know
or for lost connections uh you know i
think about these people will probably
talk about these people in berlin
who transform who's starting from
position a terrible depression
transformed their city in their country
i think about this
couple homeless couple i know very well
in vegas
so for me it's always about finding
people and solving mysteries
and i write to figure out to try to
understand the world and to figure out
what we can do about the world you know
so for me it's it's
i would i can't imagine writing a book
where i
felt i knew in advance of course i've
got ideas when i start right
i don't start as a blank slate but i
can't imagine writing a book
where i felt i knew in advance i was
standing above the reader and going
well reader you know i mean there are
books that do that you know if you've
been in it i'm a journalist i'm not an
expert
right so if you've been an expert for 30
years on
uh just read a fantastic book about
octopuses right if you guys spent 30
years studying octopuses
he knows a [ __ ] ton about octopuses i'm
very happy for him to stand above me and
say
let me tell you a little crazy [ __ ]
about octopuses that is crazy [ __ ] right
but that's great it's called other minds
i really recommend that book
um but i'm not that i'm not an expert so
for me it's about the journey come on
the journey with me come to all these
different places
come with me to a favela in rio come
with me to the killing fields in mexico
come with me to a gulag in vietnam let's
go on the journey let's figure out what
the [ __ ] going on
and of all the books and this is i know
that i can probably guess the response
here they'll hold like i'll choose your
favorite kid
which one oh chasing scream i have a
really easy answer to that
because only because um
so chasing screams a book i wrote about
the addiction and
and the war on drugs and it's because
it's the book that i've
it sounds uh so fagrandizing and wanky
but it's the book that i've seen do the
most good in the world it's a place
where i've been to
so many places where people have used
that book and the things that
to me the happiest moment in any book
and the whole process of writing
is when so i track down people i think
are really interesting and important
uh so to give an example there's a guy
in vancouver called professor bruce
alexander
one of the most amazing human beings
alive
who did a really important experiment
this transformed how we think about
addiction
called rat park i suspect we'll talk
about it and
bruce you know that experiment was known
before my book and before my ted talks
and stuff
but as bruce says you know it got a huge
boost from that
and and and that evidence is now used
was used in norway where they're just on
the brink of decriminalizing all drugs
um in all sorts of places in mexico i
remember having a surreal conversation
with some mexican politicians about it
in all sorts of different places
and to me the most exciting moment is
when the people i've written about
get in touch with me and say oh people
are contacting me because of you
because they've read about me and it's
that moment where you feel that you've
been a conduit
between someone who's doing something
really important and
people who needed to know it and to me
that's like the blissful
feeling you know so chasing the scream
just because
um that's that's what that's the book
i've seen do the most work in the world
you know what i mean quick interruption
today we have luke with us behind the
scenes watching this podcast be recorded
luke is a subscriber of this podcast and
as i said in the previous podcast we're
gonna start bringing in subscribers
to watch the show being filmed to sit
behind the scenes to and to meet me and
the guests
if you want that to be you all you've
got to do is hit the subscribe button
wherever you're listening to this
podcast
so let's talk about rap park i i read
about this study
numerous times but i think it's you know
you've probably talked about it before
but i think it's so
important and foundational for so many
reasons and and speaks actually speaks a
lot to lost connections as well
in many respects um but i would love you
to tell the story of rap park and
exactly what it what it is
you know rap park was for me i found it
very challenging when i learned about
rap park because i realized
that all my life i've been
misunderstanding some of the things i
was seeing right in front of me so like
i said we had addiction in my family
we still have addiction in my family
it's very difficult
and when i started doing the research
for chasing the scream god 10 10 years
ago exactly 10 years ago almost
i am if you'd asked me let's say her in
addiction because i was close to me if
you said to me john what causes heroin
addiction
i would have looked at you like you were
thick and i would have said well stephen
the clue's in the name
right yeah obviously heroin causes
heroin addiction right
we've been told this story for a hundred
years that's become totally part of our
common sense it was definitely part of
mine
so we think we're sitting here in east
london we think
if we kidnap the next 20 people to walk
past your flat in east london
and like a villain in a saw movie we
injected them all with heroin every day
for a month
at the end of that month they'd all be
heroin addicts for a simple reason
there's chemical hooks in heroin that as
you use it
your body starts to crave you want more
and more of them and so
at the end of that month people would
have this tremendous physical hunger for
the chemical hooks right
that's why we call it being hooked um
and that's
that's the story we have in our heads
now that story is not completely wrong
it turns out it's a very small part of a
much bigger picture
and the first thing that i remember the
first thing that alerted me to that
was in my research i was interviewing
doctors and experts and it was explained
to me right
here in britain if you and me step out
into
the street and we get hit you get hit by
a truck right god forbid terrible loss
to the world
um you'll be taken to hospital and if
you say you broke your hip
you'd be given a lot of a drug called
diamorphine right
diamorphine is heroin it's much better
than the [ __ ] you'd buy just like the
road from here
on the street because it's medically
pure heroin right
and anyone watching this if you if
you're british and your nan's had a hip
replacement operation
your nan's taken a lot of heroin right
now if what we think about addiction is
right
that it's caused primarily or entirely
by exposure to the chemical hooks
what should be happening to all these
people in british hospitals who've been
given a lot of powerful heroin
some of them should be leaving and
trying to score on the streets you
should be meeting people in their name
meetings
who say well you know i started i had a
hip replacement
this has been studied very carefully it
never happens right i remember when i
learned that
i'm just thinking the first person who
told me that was dr gabor marte
and i remember thinking saying to him
gabor that can't be right
how could you have a situation where
you've got someone in a hospital bed
they're using a [ __ ] ton of really
powerful heroin they don't become
addicted
and you've got someone in the alleyway
outside who
you know is shooting up actually a
weaker shittier form of the drug
and they and they do become addicted how
could that be and i only began to
understand it when i went to vancouver
and interviewed professor alexander
professor bruce alexander
so bruce explained to me the story we've
got in our heads that addiction is
caused primarily or totally by the
chemical hooks
comes from a series of experiments that
were done earlier in the 20th century
they're really simple experiments um
your viewers can try them at home if
they're feeling a little bit sadistic
and bored in
covid times right not heroin is it
no they don't have to try it you take a
rat you put it in a cage and you give it
two water bottles
one is just water the other is water
laced with either heroin or cocaine
if you do that the rat will almost
always prefer the drugged water
and almost always kill itself quite
quickly within a week or two right
so there you go that's that's our story
that's that's how we think it works
but in the 70s professor alexander was
working where i met him on the downtown
east side of vancouver which has a lot
of
he's working with a lot of people with
very bad addiction problems
and he starts to look at these
experiments and he says well hang on a
minute
you put the rat alone in an empty cage
it's got nothing that makes life worth
living for rats
all it's got is the drugs what would
happen if we did this differently
so he built a cage that he called rat
park which is basically
heaven for rats right they've got loads
of friends they've got loads of cheese
they've got loads of colored balls they
can have loads of sex everything that
makes life worth living
for rats is there in rat park and
they've got both the water bottles the
drugged water and the normal water
this is the fascinating thing in rat
park
they don't like the drug water they
don't use it very much
none of the music compulsively none of
them overdose
so you go from almost 100 compulsive use
and overdose
when rats don't have the things that
make life worth living
to no compulsive use and overdose when
they do have the things that make life
worth living
and obviously we are not rats we're more
complicated
but the core of this there's lots of
human evidence that i can talk about
but what what this taught me and a lot
of the other evidence taught me is
the core of addiction is about not
wanting to be present in your life
because your life is too painful a place
to be and
it actually makes you realize why our
approach of punishing people with
addiction problems is such a disaster
actually makes
the problem worse the opposite of
addiction is not sobriety although that
is valuable for some people
the opposite of addiction is connection
and we're living through a great example
of that right now just
just i think two days ago the government
announced massive increase in
alcohol-related deaths
massive increase in other drug-related
deaths in britain and in the united
states
why would that be right we i think
rightly
in order to suppress the virus which we
had to do we have had to become more
disconnected
and that has caused an increase in
addiction now that tells us something
about what was causing addiction all
along and what the paths out of
addiction are
so i thought it was a very long answer
perfect answer and obviously with the
with that in mind you know covert
has um accelerated the um
adoption of remote working which i
you know there's been a lot of debate
around that whether it's a good thing or
a bad thing
my stance is pretty clear i think it's
an awful thing and i say this because
you know after reading your book i
understand that um
connection organic connection in our
lives is
has this like has been on this sort of
macro decline and one of the like
institutions in our lives that has held
that together has been the office
so like most of my friends come from
working in a big office
you know if i think about where 90 of my
connection comes it came from the office
and to think especially as a young
person who hasn't got a family or kids
whatever
that that is also now going to move to a
screen i think is a [ __ ] terrible
idea
to be honest um i wanted to get your
your thoughts on that because i think
i i don't i think people think of the
convenience factors but
we thought of the convenience factors
when we in we created social media and
dating apps and all these other things
but the unintended consequences of the
convenience tends to be
you know stripping us of connection once
again and like what do we have left
like everything else is on a screen now
so if you take away work from me i'm
like
i probably wouldn't see anybody like
porn you know i can do that online now
dating swipe swipe swipe so it feels
like
you know the last institution of
connection is being uh is that war
i think that's really interesting i
think there's a
there's two things i was thinking about
as you talked about that stephen one is
what a lot of us get out the web the
relationship between social media and
social life
is a bit like the relationship between
porn and sex and she mentioned porn
because i'm not anti-porn porn's going
to meet a basic itch right
um but no one you know spends an hour
looking at porn and feels
like satisfied and seen speaks me
physically
not the way you do after you've had sex
right unless you're having a very bad
sex step
in a similar sort of way you know
it's not that the these
a lot of these technologies are attempts
our unhealthy relationship with the
technology itself is neutral
a lot of our relationships with these
technologies are attempts to fill
holes in the way we're living right phil
whole but unfortunately we're talking
about porn but you know what i mean
um the the the and even if you just
think about when the internet arrived
right
the internet arrives for most of us the
early 2000s or 1999 i got my first email
address in 2000
and a lot of the things that we're
talking about had already
been going rising for a long time big
increase in loneliness before that
and what happens is the internet arrives
and it looks a lot like the things we've
lost right
you've lost friends here's facebook
friends you've lost status in the
economy
here's some status updates but they're
not the things we've lost it's like
giving pawn to a sex starved man in
prison or something
it's not the thing you've lost right i
mean it'll meet a certain basic hitch
but it's not the thing you've lost
and if interacting through screens met
our basic needs as human beings
we would all be very happy zooming all
the time right sitting on zoom would be
as good as sitting in the office right
you know and people often say to me why
do you travel to so many places
to do all these interviews why don't you
just talk to them on skype or zoom and
always say
because you get 10 of the experience
through a screen people don't open up to
you they don't feel they've met you
i wouldn't remem all these people i'm
describing to you i can picture them so
vividly
people have interviewed zoom i can never
remember even what they look like right
so these forms of interaction they've
got a place you know look it's better to
have zoom in a time of a plague than
than nothing which would have been the
alternative in in the context of covid
but it's not it doesn't we evolved to
interact
to look into each other's eyes to see
each other to interact in three
dimensions
we did not evolve to interact through
screens it doesn't meet our deeper needs
that is why i've never done this podcast
over zoom despite the
temptation yeah so we we started doing
in just we started we upped everything
in december and really started going for
it you know built the team and all these
things
and that's obviously in the middle of
the pandemic there's flight restrictions
no one can fly in
and we've got the most amazing guests in
the world that want to come on via zoom
and i just said
i do this because i enjoy it right
that's like the fundamental reason
that's the reason why i'll keep doing it
for the next 10 years
and i would not enjoy doing it over zoom
it would become like a job to me because
i like
meeting people and obviously the the
conversation we have now
you can feel the emotion you can you can
hear the you know
you can see it my eyes you can see at
certain points you know you can feel
what i'm thinking
and that unlocks for a podcast that's
meant to be a little bit more
um deeper it unlocks that depth we've
had you know
tears and we've had all sorts and i
formed real friendships
from it so many pretty much all of my
guests i feel like i'm friends with it
straight after because of the
vulnerability
so i just i just made a rule that i
would not do anything over zoom and when
people ask me to go on their podcast
over zoom the answer is the same
i don't want to do it and i with my team
my office is actually downstairs
so we come in every day there is one
thing about work i think everything you
said is totally true
so there's one thing about work i would
say which is a slightly different point
uh but relates to remote working which
is so
uh i mean we can talk about some more
detail if you want but for the purposes
of this part of the conversation
there's a lot of evidence that um
lacking control over your work makes you
depressed
right i'm sure we could talk about that
more um
one thing that people do benefit from i
think from zoom not actually
funny interestingly not so much in covid
times as evidence people are working
more hours under kobe than they were
normally partly because zoom meetings
take so damn long
um but some people
i think as we come out of this which we
will
as we come out of covid um the pandemic
some people i think would like to have
more leeway about
when they are in the office oh yeah and
would like to and i think
it's interesting when you look at the
research on this
it's not so much the ratio is it 20 at
home it's whether you can choose
yes it's the amount of agency you have
um
so in that sense i think that's where
and of course we didn't have any choice
about coping but the that's the bit
where i would say
we'll probably have some value going
forward 100 agree
i i actually wrote about um motivation
intrinsic motivation
and extrinsic motivation and one of the
big factors of
people feeling motivated in work is as
you say autonomy feeling like you have
control of your work and
and that's the that's also the balance
that i've always tried to create at my
companies which is
um one way you can book um as much time
off as you need
without having to put like tell a
computer and ask it for approval
and there is no bitchiness there is no
one that's going to look at you the next
day and be like
oh you've had a couple of days off and
giving people the same level of freedom
that i've always had has been super
important
um but at the same time like i'm i've
been super clear even though it's an
unpopular narrative right now
i think this remote working future where
you know these companies are coming out
and doing all their virtual signaling
you know whatever i think it's a load of
nonsense and i think they're actually
harming
people by supporting the idea that we're
going to all
especially younger people live our lives
through screens and i think that people
are going to figure this out i actually
think
people have overestimated the stickiness
of remote remote working
because the narrative is companies that
offer remote working
will attract all the staff all the good
talent so you're gonna have to do it
but i actually think companies that are
able to offer community
and much more than work which is for me
is what a good job is much what's the
it's the friends you make the
experiences you have the challenges
you're
driving towards together the worthwhile
it's like the worth while striving for a
challenge
with a group of people you love for me
that's like become my
my the reason for why i live i i managed
to get it down to those three things
which is
people i love uh worthwhile challenge
right and i don't know how that links
into your work but that's i think the
most foundational i've managed to get
with like my reason to live is like
oh at least my reason to work so if i
think like
you've gone to a really important um
one of the most important things that
relates to depression anxiety in your
own life
which is meaning right so there's all
this i mean
it's funny exactly a year a little bit
more than a year ago a year and a month
ago i was in moscow
it was the last thing i did before i got
covered it was grim i
interviewed this fascinating uh russian
psychologist
called um dimitri leontyev and his um
so his dad had actually been a super
famous uh so his grandfather had been an
incredibly famous
psychologist but he's a very
distinguished psychologist as well and
um i remember him saying like um
british and american people british
american philosophy if you go back it's
very often about happiness the belief
that you should try to make yourself
happy
right obviously it's in constitution the
pursuit of happiness right
and he said when russians hear that we
just laugh right that's a child's game
trying to chase happiness it's the
child's philosophy so
you can't you don't have that much say
about whether happiness will come and go
he said
what life is about is not happiness but
meaning right the pursuit of meaning
and actually when you've got meaning in
your life you can tolerate a lot of
unhappiness
and you even think about something as
simple as uh a dentist or a good example
a dentist drill
right so if i now took out a drill
opened your mouth and
you know jabbed it into your teeth and
it was agony because that would have no
meaning in the context between us it
would be different it would literally be
torture it would cause you
terrible suffering and you'd be
traumatized for ages but you've been to
the dentist and they've done that right
and it didn't traumatize you most likely
some people do get traumatic dentists
that's a different story
it's rare um why because it had a
meaning right you could tolerate the
pain
because there was because it was for a
purpose all right if i don't tolerate
this pain my teeth are going to get
[ __ ] up right
um it's worthwhile and i think that's
one of the things that's a big
a big driver depression anxiety is one
actually
it was one of the two hardest causes of
depression and anxiety that i wrote
about lost connections for me to
it was the one one that was most chat
one of the two that was most challenging
for me
was this crisis of meaning so for
thousands of years philosophers have
said
if you think life is about money and
status and showing off
you're going to feel like [ __ ] right
it's not an exact quote from confucius
but that is basically what he said right
but weirdly nobody had ever
scientifically i'm looking to is this
true how do we know
no one had actually scientifically
investigated this until an amazing man i
got to know
named professor tim casa who did an
incredible amount of
uh spent 35 years researching these
questions
he discovered loads of things but i
think for what we're talking about
there's two in particular
firstly he discovered exactly as the
philosophers warned
if you think life is about money and
status and showing off
all the values you get from advertising
instagram everything like them
the more likely you are to become
depressed and anxious by a significant
amount
and secondly he discovered as a society
as a culture
we have become much more driven by these
junk
values right they've been rising all
throughout my lifetime
your lifetime and and i was talking
about well why is that right and there's
many reasons that i go through the book
why does that make us feel so bad
um a key reason i think is just
it trains us to look for happiness in
all the wrong places
right you know your technical crew know
everyone knows
everyone watching this knows you're not
going to lie on your deathbed
and think about all the likes you've got
on instagram right
you're going to think about moments of
love and meaning and connection
um but but as professor casa put it to
me
we live in a machine that is designed to
get us to neglect what is important
about life right
we live in a machine where we are
bombarded more 18 month old children
know what the mcdonald's m
means than know their own last name
right so from the moment you're born
you are trained to think if you don't
feel good there's a solution for that
work harder buy [ __ ] display on
instagram to make people go omg so
jealous right
that is the script of our society and
it's
it's like kfc for the soul right you're
not going to find happiness there
but the more meaningful values are lying
just beneath the surface right nothing i
just said i mean
it's almost like a hallmark card at the
level of banality everyone knows that at
some level
and yet we don't live by it and this is
true of a lot of things to learn from
lost connections
it's not like i'm explaining quantum
physics right it's not like i'm
not that i could do that it's not like
i'm explaining at noam chomsky's
linguistics or something
these are things at some level we all
know but we live in a machine like
professor casa put it
we live in a machine that has taught us
to neglect to mistrust our own instincts
about what will give us a good life
and to and to pursue um
other things instead do you know what i
mean does that make sense of course it
makes [ __ ] sense to me
of course it makes sense do you feel but
i really
feel the reason it was challenging is
because i could see
how much of my own life was driven by
these junk folks i was never a
materialistic person i was never
i was once nominated for an award as the
worst dressed gay man in britain so i
was never like a kind of did you in
material no i was beaten by david
furnish who i've always thought was very
well dressed so
i show so much i know but you know
a big part not i was never like i was
never like trump it was never 100
but a big part of my life
was driven by trying to think about how
people perceive me
managing people's expectations does it
still
yeah of course it's still a part of my
character but it's a radically smaller
part of my personality than it was
uh 15 years ago because i was thinking
as you're saying that i was just
thinking i was thinking this is also
true but again the question
posed my mind was how would i get out of
the machine
when so much of the things i
enjoy keep me within the machine so
you know i could i could abscond and go
to bali and go and live on a beach and
just
you surround myself with a couple of
friends and you'd give up my louis
vuitton
shoes i don't have a ton shoes but you
know what i mean give up my lamborghini
which i also don't have
and i could i could escape but much of
the joy of my life comes from doing
things like this having conversations
with people like you which means that i
have to live in london and then to
promote this i'm gonna have to use
instagram and social media and then i'm
gonna get a little pat on the back from
the algorithm if it's good or bad and
and so in the pursuit of some of my
intrinsic joy
and fit goals i i'd have played with
this a lot i
i i'm i'm putting myself in the machine
and i can't see another way to live
the best i say to myself the best you
could probably do steve
is live within the machine but just live
much more consciously
know that you're in the machine and it's
the minute that you don't know you're in
the machine that the machine becomes
your puppet master
and then i'll start [ __ ] buying louis
vuitton again so it's funny there's
doing things you're saying louis vuitton
because
i once a party met calvin klein and
until that moment i i thought calvin
klein was a fictional character
like rory mcdonald so someone said oh
this is kevin clinton i almost said
i like the clothes and then i was like
is this
like it was it was like suddenly meeting
you like ronald mcdonald or something
so i think tim caster discovered two
answers to actually lots of answers but
two specific things that he discovered
that i think really help answer your
question so
and they operate at different levels so
what can we do about the fact we live in
the machine there's two things there's
one thing that's going to sound very big
and is very big which is we can
dismantle the machine
the machine was created by human beings
and it can be dismantled and
again i went to places that have started
that sao paulo
in brazil uh city was full of
advertising it was doing people's heads
in
they banned outdoor advertising people
felt much better do you remember the
campaign that happened here when was it
it's in the books it must have been at
least four years ago five years ago
maybe
there was a campaign on the tubes skinny
too i know this is funny
yeah exactly somebody who don't remember
there were it was a picture of
a super ripped guy
and a super lean woman and it said
are you beachbody ready right and it was
an advert for some
john i'm so out of touch with sorry i
know
so what was it a protein shake it was
like a a protein a powder
right right right i'm so unhealthy i
don't even know what that powder would
you conceive of what you would do with
that powder except snort it which i
assume is not what you did but
anyway and city khan just banned it just
said you know what this makes people
feel like [ __ ] it's got an insidious
vile message which is if you don't look
like these people i.e if you're like
99.99 the population
you're not fit to go to the beach just
banned it there was a campaign to
vandalize
that poster which uh people vandalized
it just with the slogan advertising
shits in your head
so that was a great slogan so you can do
a political thing
we don't have to allow all this stuff
right um and we can build up to that in
all sorts of ways
smaller steps and one is a more personal
one
and that's something i now do i have a
group of friends we talk you know
once every couple of weeks we talk about
okay what are the times when we've been
tempted by [ __ ]
you know like uh we had the conversation
the other day and one of my friends said
you know oh
she'd got retweeted by some famous
person and it lifted her move for five
minutes and then she was like i need
more i need more i
need more and then we're like okay but
did you write that day she's writer
she said no no it distracted me i didn't
write and we're like
okay but and of course you only had to
say it don't you oh yeah
that's the thing that gives my life
meaning that's the moments when i feel
flow not the sugar high of
you know um i've tried to remember it
was it was someone really famous
um so just having these so i would say
and and those things are complementary
by the way when we have those
conversations
with the among ourselves it makes us
feel more powerful to take on
the aspects of the machine that are
[ __ ] us up as well what you've
described is like a counterbalance right
because
you've got the machine whispering in
your ear every day every time you log on
social media walk down the street look
at the internet look at the newspaper
and it's saying bye louis vuitton
[ __ ]
and then what you've described there is
just by having someone
um in your ear once in a while going
down by louis vuitton live your life for
you know intrinsic
your intrinsic values you know things
that actually matter it acts as a bit of
a counterbalance
and it's so true because i know this
stuff
right done a lot of reading about it
your book really helped me understand
it lots of other books i've you know you
talked about um
professor tim casa read his writings
after you wrote about it in your book
i know this stuff yet
once every quarter i'll pop up in the
whatsapp group with
dom and sophie and i'll go
what about a lamborghini and they'll and
they'll they'll respond to me i mean dom
goes [ __ ] get it because he's this
he's bad egg but um
he's like you might as well know but um
but my all it takes is one of my good
friends to go to me
but why do you need that and i go yeah
of course you're right but this is what
tim casa puts him really well
i remember him saying it to me we all
have a need intrinsic values but
intrinsic values are very fragile
yeah and they can be very easily
hijacked by
signaling around us which is why
you're right we need to counterbalance
it we also need to
actually get less of this [ __ ]
please right
and that's a social thing that we can
fight for right there's all sorts of
there are countries that regulate these
things sao paulo banned outdoor
advertising
there's all sorts of things we can do we
but also
um it's not just that we're bombarded
with the advertising
externally we then police that among
ourselves right when i remember when i
was a kid and people were obsessed with
nike sneakers and i was a kind of fat
kid who sat in the corner of reading i
didn't give a [ __ ] about
um uh basketball and yet i wanted these
things right
why did i and it wasn't it partly it was
exposure to advertising
but actually it was more um
the way we police it among ourselves so
once you set and train those values
people then police among themselves so
that's about how do we undo that and
it's partly about saying people
how does this really make you feel right
very occasionally you will meet an
extremely materialistic person
who will tell you that donald trump
would be a good example right
who will tell you this makes me feel
good and yet you look at them
and you see that they are achingly
unhappy right
i've rarely seen a more unhappy person
than donald trump um
so you can see but one of the dangers of
these values
is one of the reasons that makes us they
make us feel so bad
is that those values can then pollute
your relationships
when you measure it scientifically
people have high levels of junk value
what called extrinsic values is the
scientific term
people have high levels of extrinsic
values junk values
have less successful relationships that
break up more often
because relationships where you value
the other person for
very superficial external things like
you know do other men feel jealous when
they see me with this person
um those aren't good relationships right
i've been in uh
so many of them you were nodding very i
thought yeah it's just
exactly yeah no it is and um you talked
about how
you know there's the fear one of the
reasons why people are less happy in
those relationships is the fear that
this person would leave if i lost my
money or my looks whatever
and then you alluded to the point that i
was thinking most about which is
um you formed your connection with them
based on something
basically extrinsic something
superficial so you have these like
surface level connections
and then your life with that person you
don't your psychological needs don't get
met because you don't have the you know
in my case like an intellectual
connection with them you can't talk
about
the things you want to talk about you
haven't formed that basis on a deeper
level
but then i just wanted to this is if
this was a confession box
here's what i would say in the same way
that as a young
28 year old guy who's been successful um
uh you know i guess that word in my ear
that just says buy a lamborghini like a
little kermit every three months
i also get in the same year from the
same little [ __ ] evil kermit
says to me there's that a hot girl
who's completely i don't know i don't
want to get cancelled because i've got
some stuff coming up in the media but
there's that hot girl who has made
herself
look um beautiful on the outside do you
usually see the distinction stephen
right
like there's nothing wrong with sexual
attraction in front of people
we don't want to counter pose a world of
junk values versus puritanism
do you know what i mean it's like sexual
attraction is one of the great joys of
life yeah
i was just trying to i don't want to i
don't want to say it in in the words
there is that person who offers nothing
more than
um just they look good they offer
nothing more and the same way it says
come on steve go for it
and every time i've gone for it it
doesn't take me very long to be
miserable in that situation
and then on the other hand i've got
these other this other person
in my life who is the antithesis of that
who is all substance
and um something in my life tries to
sway me back to the junk
people but i think there's a thing about
um i in several ways i think
what you said is really important
because
it's not like there's this category of
saintly benign human beings
who are immune to all these temptations
and you know we need to be more like
that
every human being is a conflict of
intrinsic and extrinsic values and
extrinsic values are
a certain measure of them is healthy
right desire for external success is
nothing to be ashamed of
uh finding people hot and wanting to
have sex with hot people is perfectly
is something we all have right at the
expense of
a meaningful relationship it's like a
balanced diet isn't it you want to have
um you want these
you want these things to exist in a
balance with
all your other motivations but what i
don't think
what definitely doesn't work is because
i tried this myself i remember
being quite cut off from my own um
status seeking behavior and sort of
not owning it and i think actually
when you just acknowledge oh yeah this
is part of me this is a part this will
always be a part of me
there are some pleasures to be found
there it's not it's not barren
right um but
you always want that to be one part of a
much bigger picture then you can have a
healthy conversation
with yourself and with other people
about these aspects of yourself that's
very different to
and especially if you live in a society
and culture that is all about
getting you to be that one thing and you
know presenting as images of success
i mean you and i both met lots of rich
people
and i've got to say they are the most
miserable bastards
or you're one of the very few cheerful
rich people i know right
if i think about says a handful who are
happy and they're almost
always uh i'm trying to think of
i can look well one person who inherited
it so i don't count that
um some artistic people like a few
people who
pursued their artistic dream like elton
john and became really rich he's happy
after a [ __ ] rocky journey as
everyone knows
and the machine that's [ __ ] us all up
do you believe that because it's
making us all care it's conditioning us
to care more about extrinsic values and
these
like you know all this nonsense do you
think it's in
it's it's hindering our chances of
forming meaningful
romantic connections i for just from
what i've grown up in this instagram era
where it looks like
everybody's getting prettier on the
outside and everyone's getting uglier in
the inside
because instagram and the machine have
told us that this is what society values
how big is your ex how white is your why
how perfect is your hair you know
so it feels like life is gone okay the
game everybody get in get in everybody
get in okay
you're gonna this is how you win you'll
get the most points in life if you have
the best hair the best uh eyes the best
boobs you know biggest six-pack
chest that is the game do you understand
everyone's going yeah okay okay and if
you see someone that has that as well
pam on the back and we go okay cool and
we've had ten years of this black mirror
experiment
so all of our values have gone you know
extrinsic and junk values
and i think we're struggling to form
meaningful
connections because that didn't the
machine told us
that didn't matter you know it's funny
after the book came out
a group of people i did not expect to so
i was
absolutely inundated on it was
particularly my ted talk about it came
out
inundated on instagram by massive
instagram
yeah um start what we call it influences
like really people with some of the
biggest instagram followings in the
world
messaging me saying you're so right i
feel like and i remember getting a
message i
always say who it was but from someone
who was a big instagram influencer
messaging me saying i'm so depressed
i don't want to get a bed in the morning
my life is terrible i
didn't hear this person also i clicked
on the instagram page and literally five
minutes before sending me that message
and five minutes after
yeah she had done a kind of glowing my
life is you know i can't know the words
but you know kind of my life is so great
um bragging and and i really
yes but the thing i would say
that is so important about this it's a
funny thing to say i know it might sound
odd
but the widespread nature of our
depression anxiety and addiction crises
in one sense although
terribly painful and horrible and
excruciating and i've been there
is a positive thing because
the system is not working for more and
more people
and it becomes harder to defend this
system and these values
when it makes everyone feel like [ __ ]
right
at some point you have to go you know
what this ain't [ __ ] working for us
so think about where we are i lived here
as i said for 10 years right just
not far from here so tower hamlets
you know i mean the tahoe says some of
the hot i think
if i remember rightly when i lived here
it was i think it was the constituency
in england that had the highest level of
poverty right
um so there's a lot of distress in tower
hamlets right i mean and by the way you
can be distressed and not be poor a lot
of this distress is happening in
middle class and wealthy areas but think
about where we are look for signs of
distress
connect with the people who are
distressed fight together with them for
something better
and of course that has to be something
people do i can't tell people what the
signs of distress around them are and
they'll be different
in you know um a coastal village in kent
to
you know glasgow where my mom's from to
the isle of skye
different there'll be certain shared
factors but
look for the signs of distress i mean
you're spoiled
for signs of distress they're all
[ __ ] around us right
i mean think about um the number of
people who drank themselves to death in
britain last year and how much that went
up as we said
and then meet them where they are
because god
change is really possible right and i
think about that in my own life
you know i'm gay right i didn't hear the
concept of gay marriage till i was 20
and my friend andrew sullivan wrote the
first book advocating it right literally
i did never crossed my mind i remember
the first person i was ever in love with
when i was 16.
i never had a sense of a future didn't
even occur to me that we could get
married it never even
entered my head right um you think about
the scale of that transformation
i remember just before kovid i was on
the tube
and there were these two girls who can't
have been more than 16
and they were making out and i was
staring at them and i think they thought
i was like an elderly person
and i had to go oh no no i'm gay i'm
just really this is really moved this
could never happen when i was your age
like i said i just thought i was like a
mental person but
the the how did that happen right
it happened because ordinary people
came out they appealed to other people
around them
lots of heterosexual people saw that it
was
pointless to be cruel to gay people and
they could be loving and accepting
instead
and that change happened unbel you
basically got
2 000 years of gay people being
horrifically persecuted
and then like 70 years of this from
from less than 70 years 60 years from
send them to prison to yay they can get
married right
so absolutely change on when we talk
about things like oh
you know we're trapped in this machine
that's making us depressed right
that can sound like such a big thing
right we had
2 000 years of homophobia right and i'm
not saying we've completely overcome it
obviously
but there's stunning progress right
the things we're talking about are much
more recent inventions than homophobia
right
like infinitely more recent and
homophobia
terrible though it was only ever
affected a small part of the population
the things we're talking about
[ __ ] make they don't make everyone
depressed but they make everyone less
happy than they could be
so these are you know these are
absolutely things that can be challenged
they can be challenged in individuals
lives
and we can deal with them at the
political level as well
it requires a transformation in
consciousness which is happening
and we can talk about addiction if you
want in places that solved
that made extraordinary changes in that
and massively reduce their addiction
deaths that i went to
but we need to understand this
differently and we need to listen to our
pain
we need to stop insulting our depression
anxiety and addictions
by saying they're a sign of weakness or
madness or
purely biological although there are
some biological contributions
and start listening to them listen to
the signal as a society
and as a culture because it is telling
us
where we need to go and what we need to
do i've been a hill fan for a long time
as you obviously know by now but in the
last six months i've got a real
opportunity to get to know the people to
get to know the ceo of huell which is
james to get to know the founder which
is julian
the teams that agonize over the
ingredients that go into these amazing
recipes
and i can honestly say with my hand on
my heart my appreciation
and admiration for huel and its people
has multiplied by a factor of 10
because and this is the singularities
not only are they nice people
but because i've seen first hand how
much they are non-negotiable
about the values of huel they will not
compromise they will not compromise
on the the goodness of the ingredients
that goes into the products the amount
of
proteins and minerals and these things
regardless if they can't get to where
they want to get to with the products
they will cancel the product i've tasted
products and they've said we've not
managed to make it this
we've not delivered on our promise of
veganism we've not added enough fiber
so we're canceling it and that sort of
non-negotiable set of values
has made me realize that they have my
back when i choose cure
let me talk about you okay
and your connections yeah and your
romantic connections your friendships
and all of those things
sometimes i find it fascinating that
obviously since you know people can
know a lot of stuff but applying it to
oneself is challenging
i've you know some of my my favorite
guests that i've sat here with i'm
thinking about jamal
kreishi who i sat here with who's like a
you know you one could call him like a
motivational
uh coach you know probably doesn't quite
characterize who he is but
my last question to him was um are you
good at taking your own advice he went
absolutely [ __ ] not he was like i'm
the least motivated motivational coach
in the world
so my question to you is how are you
doing with your connections in your life
in your
mental health and all of these questions
i think people are often most articulate
about the things they most struggle with
right so and it's interesting because
sometimes that's presented as hypocrite
give you an example
there's a left-wing political who but
there's a left-wing politician
i know who is incredibly articulate
about greed
and how terrible it is and is incredibly
greedy right
now you could look at that and go that's
hypocrisy
and of course at one level a kind of
boringly obvious level it is
but to me what's more interesting is
that is a person who's internally
struggling against his own flaw
right that is a person who has this
force within him
and is genuinely trying is so articulate
because he's wrestling with it all the
time
and so i think um in a sense taking your
own advice is sort of like
the fact that you needed to articulate
the advice suggests that internal
struggle do you know what you mean yeah
i think about um ian foster
one of my favorite writers who famously
said only connect
who was someone who really struggled
with connection um
partly because he was a gay man of a
much earlier generation
who uh well his connections
his loving romantic connections were a
crime right so he was really
there were other ways in which he
struggled with with connection as well
so in terms of myself
um i was always very lucky with
friendships
um all my life i've had amazing
friendships
for me um you know i said before there
were two causes of
two cause out of the nine causes of
depression anxiety that wrote about in
the book there were two that i struggled
with a lot
and this so one was drunk values the
other
it this was a hard journey for me in the
book
i learned about this through a story of
a scientist discovered it
who i met and she explained i think
people understand it better if they know
the story even though for like a minute
you're going to think
what the [ __ ] has this got to do with
what he just said but just bear with me
so in the mid 1980s there was a doctor
called vincent felitti
who um was approached
he was in san diego in california and he
was approached by kaiser permanente who
are one of the big not-for-profit
medical providers in california
and they came to him and were like we've
got a problem
and we need your help and the problem
was
um obesity
obesity was massive rising hugely
exploded since then but it was
rising and rising and they were like
look nothing we're doing is working we
give people diet advice we talk to them
about nutrition
we even give some of them personal
trainers nothing is working
so they just gave him a quite big budget
and said just do blue skies research
work with really obese people
just figure out what the hell we can do
so dr felitti starts working with
uh 250 severely obese people people who
weighed more than 400 pounds so people
who are really
you know in terrible danger he's working
on this thing
he's interviewing them he's thinking
what can i do and
one day he's talking to one of them and
he has an idea
which sounds like it actually is a quite
stupid idea
he said what would happen if really
obese people
literally stopped eating and we gave
them like
i know vitamin c shot so they didn't get
scurvy we gave them like
vitamin shots would they just burn
through the fat supplies in their body
and get down to a normal way
so with a [ __ ] ton of medical
supervision they try it
and incredibly at first it worked
there's a woman i call her susan that's
not a real name
um who went down from being more than
400 pounds to 138 pounds it's amazing
right
and people are like how can this be
what's going on uh and her family are
like you've saved her life
and then one day something happened they
didn't expect susan cracked
she went to kfc she wasn't kfc that's me
projecting whatever it was
uh some fast food place she starts
obsessively eating
and pretty soon she's back at her
dangerous weight not where she'd been
but a dangerous weight
and dr felitti called her in he's like
susan what happened
said i don't know i don't know
and he's kind of dumbfounded and he says
well tell me about the day that you
cracked what
did anything happen that day it turned
out something had happened that day that
never happened to susan
she was in a bar and a man came up to
her and hit on her not in a nasty
predatory way in a nice way
and she felt really freaked out and she
goes and she starts eating and
if he's like huh what's the significant
could this be significant and then he
said to her
saying he never asked his patients
before he said susan when did you start
to put on your weight
in her case it was when she was 11.
and he said to her well did anything
happen that year that didn't happen any
other year anything when you're eleven
she said she looked down she said yeah
that's when my grandfather started to
rape me
dr philippe interviewed everyone in the
program and he discovered that more than
60 percent of them have put on their
extreme weight in the aftermath of being
sexually abused or assaulted
and he's thinking what's what's that
about how what
and susan explained it to him really
well she said overweight is overlooked
and that's what i need to be this thing
that seems so destructive and of course
it's bad for you to be severely obese
was performing a positive function for
all these people it was protecting them
from sexual attention
right um and just things like ah this is
this is kind of interesting um so he
but this is a small group of people it's
250 people it's not much you can't
draw big scientific conclusions based on
this so
dr felitti goes to the cd center for
disease control who fund a lot of
medical research
and he got funding to do a massive study
everyone
who came to kaiser permanente in san
diego so more than 17 000 people
for a whole year no matter what for
headaches schizophrenia broken leg
anything
got given two questionnaires first part
says
did you have any of these bad
experiences when you were a kid things
like sexual abuse
severe neglect that kind of thing second
part said
um have you had any of these problems as
an adult it was initially only going to
say
obesity but and this is where it comes
to our story at the last minute they had
loads of other things like depression
addiction suicide attempts
and at first when they added up the
figures people they were like no there's
been a mistake added up again
because the figures were so extreme for
every category of childhood trauma that
you experienced
you were two to four times more likely
to be depressed obese and addicted
but when you got into the multiple
categories the figures just went crazy
if you had six categories of chance of
trauma
you were 3100 more likely to have
attempted suicide
and 4 600 percent more likely to have an
injecting
drug problem i mean these are just
insane figures you very rarely get that
in science right
and i remember dr felitti saying to me
like that that he he realized
it was like there had been a house fire
and we have been focusing on dealing
with the smoke
not on dealing with the fire right dr
robert ander who's one of the other
scientists who worked on it said to me
he realized when you see things like
obesity depression addiction
we need to stop asking what's wrong with
you and start asking
what happened to you but
it's kind of difficult to talk about
this but so dr felicia is a super nice
guy right if you met him you'd really
like him when i interviewed him he was
like
81 so ages ago lovely
good decent admirable man
and when i interviewed him in san diego
the first time i was sitting with him
and i was getting angrier and angrier
and i actually ended the interview early
because i was getting so angry
i remember walking to the beach in san
diego walking around thinking
what the [ __ ] is this about why am i so
angry with this lovely old man who's
done this amazing research that's helped
so many people
and i'm thinking so
when i was a child i'd experienced some
very extreme things from an adult in my
life
and i had i didn't want to think about
that i didn't want to
uh i didn't want to think about that in
relation to the depression i had
experienced
i didn't i didn't want to give this
individual power over me now
um but one of the reasons
i'm glad that i went back and carried on
talking to him is because of what dr
felicity
do you think is really relevant to what
you're asking so
obviously they'd asked all these people
who came for healthcare about their
childhood trauma
so suddenly they've got all this data so
they said to people's gps don't call
them back in
but next time they come in look at the
childhood trauma thing and if they've
experienced childhood trauma say to them
something like this
i see that when you were a child you
were sexually abused or whatever it was
i'm really sorry that happened that
should never have happened to you you
should have been protected that was a
failing
would you like to talk about it and 40
percent of people did not want to talk
about it but 60
of people did and they wanted to talk
about it on average for five minutes
and then it was randomly assigned some
of them were told we can go to
therapists to talk about it more
what they found was just five minutes of
an authority figure saying
i'm so sorry this should never have
happened to you that alone
led to a significant fall in depression
and anxiety and people who refer to a
therapist had an even bigger form
and what this shows it fits with a whole
load of other evidence from people like
professor steve coles at ucla professor
james pennebaker at florida state
university
is it's not the trauma that destroys you
it's the shame about the trauma and
giving people
ways to release that shame is an
antidepressant
so for me
learning that and it's one of the
reasons i made myself put it in the book
and talk about it
is so very often people who survive
abuse as children
internalize the voice of the abuser
right almost invariably the abuser says
you made me do this you're a bad person
you made me do this
right and so although of course there
was never any point in my adult life
where i
thought that was a rational you know
there was never a point where i would
have if you
you know if someone had told me they had
been abused and told me negative things
they'd been told
i would never have thought yeah the
abuser was right obviously
i didn't reckon with that
internalization in my own life and i
think it meant that
a lot of the time although i always had
great friendships
with romantic relationships um
they would i would often cauterize them
at a certain point
because i didn't feel at that time that
i deserved to be loved
i didn't feel that i deserved to be
treated well so it would mean that
sometimes i would get into relationships
people who didn't treat me well
or sometimes if they did treat me well i
would end it prematurely
at the point at which they were treating
me well because i've internalized so
many of these negative
uh and destructive and untrue ideas
and and the process of thinking that
through obviously i had a therapist as
well
the process of thinking that through and
releasing that shame made me
much more open to
know love you know uh because i didn't
it was possible to overcome that does
that make sense stephen does that are
you still on that journey
oh yeah and i think anyone who you know
how would i put it yeah of course
of course
and through all of your your work and
your writing you've you know
you've highlighted to the world but also
clearly to yourself the importance of
that
um of romantic connections well it comes
right back to where we started isn't it
why do i write to understand to
understand things i didn't understand at
the start
to go on a journey there are things i
want to understand
um and and sometimes they're big things
right
um and sometimes they're very personal
things and sometimes they're both
uh and then to track down okay who
who knows a lot about this who's found
interesting things out about this and go
and sit with them
and kind of pester them and keep going
back year after year until
i feel i understand it and i feel now i
understand it
and i gotta say it's quite frustrating
watching some of the kovid debate at the
moment because um
there's been this big increase in
addiction depression
and a lot of the way it's taught even by
super well-meaning
admirable people as almost everyone in
this debate is
so many of the ways in which people are
encouraged to think they are helping
people
with the best will in the world and with
a good heart
often strip these things of meaning
so there's a thing for example that very
well meaning people say which is so
depression is just like you know
depression is
a disease like diabetes you know
you wouldn't shame someone having a
broken leg
they're absolutely right that depressing
anxious people should never be
stigmatized but actually that
that's not the way you remove stigma you
don't remove i mean
no one ever doubted that leprosy and
aids were biological phenomena
and you might notice there was a damn
lot of stigma about them right saying
something is biological and it's true
there are some biological components we
can talk about if you want
some biological contributions your genes
can make you more vulnerable to these
things so they do not write your destiny
um but but sexting is biological does
not actually the
there's some good scientific evidence it
it increases the stigma because it makes
people think god those people are really
different to me they're like a
different species what actually undoes
stigma is to say although there are some
biological contributions any of us would
feel like this in this situation
actually that your pain makes
sense there was a moment that really all
this really fell into place for me as
well as one of the two
totally revolutionary moments for me in
the research for lost connections i went
to interview
this south african psychiatrist called
derek summerfield
and he told me this story about
something that happened to him so
derek was in cambodia in 2001 when they
first introduced chemical
antidepressants for people in cambodia
they've never had them in the country
before
and the local doctors the the cambodians
were like
what are they they didn't know what they
were antidepressants
and and derek explained and they said to
him oh we don't need them we've already
got antidepressants and he was like well
what do you mean
he thought they were going to talk about
some kind of like herbal remedy like
jinkobeloba or something
instead they told him a story they had a
farmer in their community
who worked in the rice fields and one
day he stood on a land mine
left over from the wall with the
americans and he got his leg blown off
so they gave him an artificial limb they
did that in cambodia because they've got
a lot of land mines
and after a while several months the guy
goes back to work right so he goes back
to work in the rice fields
and but apparently it's super painful to
work under water when you've got an
artificial limb
and i'm guessing it was pretty traumatic
to go back and work in the field where
he got
blown up the guy started to cry all day
after a while he just wouldn't get out
of bed he developed what we would call
classic depression right this is when
the cambodian doctor said well you know
that's when we gave him an
antidepressant and derek said what was
it
they explained that they went and sat
with him they listened to him
they realized that his pain made sense
he only had to talk to him for five
minutes to realize why he felt so [ __ ]
one of the doctors said well we realized
if we bought this guy a cow
he could become a dairy farmer he
wouldn't be in this position that was
screwing him up so much
so they bought him a cow within a couple
of weeks his crying stopped
within a month his depression was gone
it never came back they said to derek
so you see doctor that cow that was an
antidepressant that's what you mean
right
now if you've been raised to think about
depression the way we have that it's
primarily or entirely a malfunction in
your brain
that sounds like a bad joke i went to my
doctor for an antidepressant she gave me
a cow
but what those cambodian doctors knew
intuitively from this individual
unscientific anecdote
is what the leading medical body in the
whole world the world health
organization
has been trying to tell us for years
right your pain
makes sense if you're depressed if
you're anxious
you're not weak you're not crazy you're
not
in the main a machine with broken parts
you're a human being with
unmet needs and what you need is
practical help and support
to get those needs met so one of the
things we have to be asking as a society
and culture is
what's the cow for the things that are
screwing us up right what's the cow for
the things that are making us depressed
instead of seeing depression as a
malfunction
we've got to see it as a signal that's
telling us the person is distressed
and and has unmet needs and and together
help them get those disparate because
what the doctors didn't say is
all right mate this is your problem
you're on your own right together they
help to solve the problem
we've got to solve the underlying
problems for which depression is a
signal
and you said you tweeted um about this
you said um
there is good evidence that after covid
we can reverse our
spiraling depression and anxiety crisis
but to do that we need to radically
expand the menu of responses to it
yeah think about what we were talking
about to give one example just from up
the road
social prescribing right every single
doctor's surgery should have a social
prescribing wing
it should be the first thing that is
suggested certainly for mild and
moderate depression
uh is figure out if the person's lonely
and
disconnected from the natural world if
they are suggest they might prescribe
and there's a real power in doctors
prescribed not just saying oh you might
want to think about this
because people feel so disempowered to
find each other in such a
lonely and atomized society that's one
example obviously the last third of lost
connections
is loads of very practical examples and
we have to do that in our own lives
right like we can
socially prescribe ourselves yeah i
think there's an authority in doctors
absolutely we can we shouldn't we should
be doing it for ourselves we should be
urging other people to do it
but in a culture that's become so
disconnected
from understanding our needs and
actually where we've been told a rival
story
that has some truth in it you know there
are as i
stress a lot in the book i have a
chapter about this there are real
biological contributions to
depression and anxiety that can make you
more sensitive to these problems
and can make it harder to get out but
what's happened is
an overly simplified biological story
has become
the main thing we say about depression
when i went to my doctor and i was a
teenager and i was felt like pain was
leaking out of me
my doctor who was a very well-meaning
decent person just said the same wrong
with your brain and all you need to do
is drug yourself
right and chemical anti-depressants gave
me a little bit of relief for a while
also gave me really severe side effects
in my case although not everyone
and ultimately i remain depressed right
so what that story did that over
simplified story which has some truth in
it for some people
well that oversimplified story did is
cut me off for many years for
13 years from exploring the deeper
causes
if right early on there's no criticism
of my doctor they're just part of a
system you know that's not of their own
creation and a lot of doctors want to do
better and want to have better options
to give people that
they haven't been offered them
themselves
and it cut me off from a deeper more
nuanced story
that helps me to find a way out of my
depression so i think one of the things
we've got to do is
help people to find stories that make
sense of their pain
because that's the way once you
understand why you feel something you
can begin to find your way out of it
but just being lost in a haze if you're
just biologically broken no one is
there are some biological contributions
but no one is broken by their biology
no one is no one is with there's nobody
who with the right support can't find
their way out
but with the right support is a crucial
clause there
that we have to build as a society that
we have not built right
we just haven't built got me thinking
about psychedelics
for a number of reasons because
psychedelics you know it's been of a
i think there's a bit of a revolution
going on in the the perception of
psychedelics you know we had the war and
nixon's like war on drugs in the like
50s or 60s or whatever it was i wasn't
alive then so
excuse my uh inaccuracy but we were
lucky you dodged the bullet of nixon
not a good guy yeah i wasn't there
either but i'm not ready to talk about
him but i just i know that he was
pivotal in like you know
slamming the the gauntlet down on the
the chance of
even researching some of these compound
psychedelic compounds but what i've
come to learn over the last six months
working in uh you know one of the
world's leading um sort of psychedelic
and non-psychedelic mental health
companies which is a tie
and spending some time there is how
remarkable
the s these stats evidence and findings
are
um for things like psilocybin which is
the compound derived from
magic mushrooms at helping those with
treatment-resistant depression to
overcome
um their you know their their feelings
of depression
and it matches up perfectly to the
philosophy and really the
the perspective that your book gave me
on mental health because
it approaches the um the
what's the correct word to use the
indication of treatment resistant
depression
from the stance that something has
happened to you and that thing might
live in your subconscious
you know and it's an unlocker of that
thing in the same way that therapy might
be for some for some people
but what's your you know having written
this book and studied
depression for so long and anxiety
what do you think of psychedelics so as
you know for the book
as chapter about psychotics because i
went and interviewed the leading experts
in the world on this people who've been
doing the
cutting-edge research i interviewed them
in um johns hopkins in baltimore
at ucla here in london at ucl at nyu
and somewhere else oh in brazil and um
so i'm strongly informed of psychedelics
for some people it's a slightly
complicated picture
in a way that i think helps us to
understand what's going on
so think about treatment you mentioned
treatment resistant depression some
really good research was done on this
here in london
by david professor david nutt and dr
robin carhart harris
they get people who've been depressed
for a long time and nothing's helped
them and they've tried lots of things
and nothing's helped them
and they gave them remember rightly
three doses of psilocybin in the active
component magic mushrooms might be wrong
on the number but
something like that and exactly as you
say
huge numbers of them have a
it's amazing they feel the strong
feeling of connection
to the natural world to their own
traumas to everyone around them as
anyone as you see psychedelics
experience a really profound spiritual
experience
and that deeply lifts their depression
and anxiety
so a taste of connection this wasn't
true for literally everyone but it was a
very high percentage
an intense feeling of meaning and
connection helps to lift them out of
their depression
there's a coder to that which robin
talks about um
so i'll give you an example one of the
people who told me about it's a woman in
the program who worked in
um she worked in an office in like a
coastal town in britain that was quite
kind of run down and grim
should be very depressed she goes she
takes the silocybin
her depression lifts she feels deeply
connected and then she goes back to work
in
the office and she comes back and is
like
i can't go around my office acting like
we're connected we're all equal
nature is beautiful i have to live in
this disconnected way to exist in my
office right
so over time her depression comes back
because
she's had a taste of connection but then
she goes back to live in a disconnected
landscape
right a disconnected emotional landscape
and i think um so what the evidence
shows
is the way i think of psychedelics is
administered in the right way of course
that's an important clause
what they can do is give you a taste of
how it feels to be connected
to have meaning but i think of that as
like
a compass that can point you in the
direction you need to travel
it doesn't do the j it gives i mean it
gives you a flash of what it's like to
be at the end of the journey
but then you're back at the start of the
journey and you know the com you know
the direction in which you need to
travel
what it doesn't do is do the journey for
you right or not for more than the six
or seven hours
you know you're you're under the effects
of the the psychedelic
so and this is true of a lot of the
i mean there's some i'll come to some
complexity of the evidence in a minute
but
so most people are not going to want to
take psychedelics a huge amount at the
time right i mean there's some
exceptions amanda fielding i don't know
if you met her
so amanda who people don't know amanda
is um kind of amazing
uh british heiress who's a great
champion of psychedelics
who um seems to remember i don't want to
get it wrong cause i didn't write about
her so i didn't uh i don't remember the
exact number but
i seem to call her saying she took
psychedelics for the whole of 1986. so
just every day right so some people will
have the means and want to take
psychedelics all the time
but that's a very small part of the
population right so
what what we know works is giving people
psychedelics
to give them a sense of what it can be
like to be connected and then helping
them
to integrate into their lives ways they
can bring
take that connection forward so there
was a guy i interviewed who was part of
the johns hopkins study
who had had this very profound
experience with psychedelics
his dad had died when he was very young
no one had talked to him about his dad's
death when he died it was just kind of
silence
and when he died he had this vision
where his he saw his dad he found his
dad in a wood
and his dad said to him you know you
built up these walls to protect yourself
but we can take these walls down now
you're safe go and seek right because
he'd been cutting himself off for so
long from
from things like romantic connections
and then
when he when the psychedelics the effect
of the psychedelics
the immediate effect of the psychedelics
went away he then started becoming like
a very deep meditator
doing all sorts of things that kind of
built in
that that that sense of connection into
his life so i think
that that to me is the great value of
now there are some people who say they
have more enduring effects beyond just
that immediate taste of connection and
the
my kind of compass metaphor so the good
evidence for that would be the johns
hopkins study
so the guys at johns hopkins did her
amazing scientists did it
i always think about this in relation to
my mother because um they took
really long-term smokers so my uh my
mother smokes 70 cigarettes a day
and uh there's an amazing there's a
photo of me and her two at a time
she's like there's a photo of me and her
when i'm uh about six months old i found
a few years ago
where she's um she's breastfeeding me
smoking and resting the asteroid in my
stomach
and when i showed it to her she said my
mother's scottish uh what
i showed it to her she said you were a
difficult baby i needed that cigarette
[ __ ] [ __ ]
but um so they took people like my
mother who a super super long-term
smoker she's been spoken since she was
14.
and they gave them i think it was three
doses of silocybin over a few months
and 80 of them stopped smoking and a
year later
60 of them were still non-smokers so
there's some evidence of
though positive long-term outcomes it's
quite a small study
so yeah i think this is a really
important i think some people oversell
it and say it's
the answer which is not right but i
think it can be a very useful tool when
i talk about
with depression what we've done up to
now
is basically since the since the 90s
is with depression when people present
with depression
almost all the time there is one option
on the menu which is chemical
antidepressants
which do give some people some relief um
we need to
radic that needs to stay on the menu but
we need to radically expand the menu of
options
and psychedelics are another great
example of something that should totally
be
beyond the menu should be available to
people
in a medical context and i would argue
outside medical context as well
i mean it's part of the argument of um
my book chasing the scream about how we
need to end the war on drugs
and move towards regulated models of
access to drugs for all sorts of drugs
so
yeah i think i think it's really
important i think we're getting there as
well it's uh
you know the public markets and the
commercial model and the amount of
investment that's going into
psychedelics is just
staggering a thai have raised i think
400 million
in the last 24 months it's another thing
where
you know we're thinking about change
when we feel like we're up against when
we are indeed
up against these very powerful forces
what think about cannabis right yeah
when the day george w bush becomes
president in 2000
15 of american citizens support
legalizing cannabis
today it's 70 and because new york just
legalized
uh that hasn't started yet they've just
voted the legislature voted to legalize
now half of all american citizens live
in a state where cannabis is legal right
so you think about how quickly that
happened cannabis being unbelievably
demonized from the 1930s to the to
the to like your lifetime yeah um
and then this huge shift in opinion
really quickly
because people saw it in practice right
people saw cannabis legalization and
practice colorado went first
um mason taver who led that campaign i
interviewed a lot for chasing the screen
just all it takes is one place to breach
the damn two places washington state did
at the same time
and people are like oh is this the thing
we were so [ __ ] afraid of
oh actually you know it's you know
pretty straightforward
just i feel like social media has played
it played a role in this because
we now have this like connected
consciousness of like a whole country or
the whole planet
where we can we can pick up on an idea
share it
and like virtue signal it signal it
rapidly
into existence into where we all go yep
that's right yeah
like a whole country can do it when you
think about if you go back hundreds of
years before the advent of the internet
if the king of the land or whatever the
politician had said something
we couldn't um sort of get together in
the same way
and um form our own opinion as this like
because i see like
i think about twitter as this one brain
and
one day it will say you know same-sex
marriage is
great and that idea can very quickly
become adopted because you can get that
idea to
like a billion people and basically vote
it into existence using like
you know likes and retweets and a couple
of influences
and so i you know so i would have said
that if you
i would have said that 10 years ago what
you just said i would have had the
optimistic view i think the evidence
since then has gotten
you're definitely right one of the good
things about social media is we're
geographical distance feels much more
collapsed
and we feel much closer to the whole
world ideas are spreading yeah and i
just
but if you look at the mechanisms by
which those ideas
spread this is not inherent to social
media this is inherent to the current
business model of social media
so if you look at my friend tristan
harris uh has done his
totally interview has done a really
important work on this he was a google
engineer
who uh saw what was happening inside
google and
and spoke out um
so if you look at how these ideas spread
so we tend to think of it as a neutral
playing field right
so here's a good idea gay marriage
psychedelics help depression whatever it
might be
enters this level playing field some
people like it it spreads it grows right
now sometimes that happens of course
but if you look at um so these business
models of premise the business model of
youtube twitter facebook is all promised
on
you pick up your phone now you scroll
through twitter you scroll through
facebook
the longer you are scrolling the more
money facebook makes obviously because
of
both exposure to adverts and because
they're learning more about you every
time you do anything
so their business model is premised
every time you put down your phone it's
a disaster for them
and every time you carry on scrolling
it's great for them so they've designed
very complex algorithms
to figure out what keeps you scrolling
what keeps everyone who walks past this
building scrolling
and it turns out because of the quirky
human beings that we could talk about
well if you want
things that make you angry will keep you
scrolling longer
than thing things that out things things
that outrage and anger you will keep you
scrolling
longer than things that make you feel
good if you see something that makes you
feel good
it makes you want to go and be out in
the real world if you see something that
makes you angry you want to keep
scrolling you want to express your rage
right
if it's enraging it's engaging so
although that's not the goal of youtube
and facebook they want you to be angry
their algorithms are figured out
angering and enraging content
keeps people scrolling longer therefore
although it's not the intention of the
designers
the the practical effect of these apps
is
they are designed to make the algorithms
function in such a way
that they will feed you things that make
you angry and upset so this thing that
you thought was a level playing field
right oh
good ideas will prevail bad ideas or die
out is not right
actually on in the main it will select
for things that make people angry so you
look at the nyu study
if you look at the um the figures for
the 2016 u.s presidential election
i think the figure was 19 out of 19 out
of the 20 most uh
shared stories on facebook were lies
like actual lies like
the trumpet um donald trump was endorsed
by the pope right which was not true in
fact the pope
criticized donald trump um so you see
when
you think about infowars the disgusting
filth
uh this guy alex jones who
uh is a a cynic cynic not even
not even a lunatic a cynic who says
things like
the sandy hook massacre didn't happen
the parents
were are liars they're crisis actors so
you think about you know
how many children it was 26 i think were
murdered at school
and he unleashes a mob against these
parents whose children
have been murdered where those parents
have had to move loads of times because
they are
hounded by his supporters threatening to
kill their surviving children
it's hard for me to imagine a more evil
thing
infowars in the 2016 election
more infowars stories were shared on
facebook in the world than the entire
new york times washington post guardian
and bbc combined
so you think about this landscape that
is enraging people
um so it's not now
you don't have to have a business model
like that social media doesn't have to
work that way
right you can have all the good things
about social media the
collapsing of social distance the
connection of the world without that if
you have a different business model we
can talk about another time
and tristan talks about that brilliantly
but
so i i i get what you're saying and i
understand
there's a truth in what you're saying
which is we can hear ideas more readily
but there's a cost well it's not just a
cost there'll be a cost in any model
but actually we're communicating through
a poisoned
mechanism that doesn't promote the
spread of good ideas that actually
promotes the spread of false
and uh hateful ideas um and we've got to
fix
that as well as um
yes then we can have all the joys of
connection without this you know
infowars [ __ ] or or other forms of
i completely agree um and you you know i
saw you'd written
when you went off to write your new book
which we're not we're probably not
allowed to talk about on this uh
my publishers will tase me that's fine
they've told me very specifically
i'm super excited to read it it's
january next year january next year yeah
how exciting yeah
can you you can say the title that's on
amazon uh it's called stolen focus
nice okay i'm not i'm
why you can't focus and how to think
deeply again okay but my publishers
literally
don't i can't do an american accent
that's a [ __ ] word they don't
actually smell like that i've told them
like they're the
they're actually like very nice new york
we won't talk about that
but um what i would like to talk about
is focus
what are you doing in that process where
you're writing you're writing a new book
now what are you doing
are you out researching you're on the
internet you're reading other books
you're speaking to people what are you
doing
so i spend a lot i spent a long time
researching my book so the book that i'm
gonna
the book that i'm writing now which is
about i'm really not meant to talk about
because it's about a specific set of
crimes that
uh other people have written about i
don't want to i don't want to set up the
journalists
but um so i've been going there for 10
years
and i've been getting to know the people
10 years and i've been
deeply researching it for 10 years and
there's a thing about
um when you're trying to understand a
subject whether it's depression or las
vegas or i'm writing a biography of name
chomsky that i've also been working on
for a really long time
and i probably won't write for another
10 years at least
there's a thing about such an important
part of my books is people opening up to
me
and people generally don't open up to
you the first time they meet you you
know they think who is this person why
does he want why do you want to ask me
these very personal questions what's
going on here
generally people open up to you at the
end of the second year so for me
it's so important it's incredible
privilege and luxury that i get to do
this
um for me what's so important is this
very
long span so i'll spend ten years
writing in in this moment since you know
what i'm doing at the moment
so i'm writing about vegas so there's a
couple tommy and shea
who i knew over many years uh when
he was murdered um and what i'm doing at
the moment
is i've got all the audio i've ever
recorded i've got
hundreds of hours of audio with them i
paid to have it all transcribed and i'm
just
reading through just mounds and mounds
of transcripts they keep all right
that's a scene that's a moment ah i
forgot he said that
you know this is that's the time this
happened to us that's the time we were
you know in caesar's palace and then oh
yeah and the guy so it's just going
through
so at the moment i'm in the stage of
what i think of as
finding out what jigsaw pieces i've got
i'm not even assembling the jigsaw at
the moment i'm just going over okay
and you know there'll be i'll read 300
pages of transcripts and think oh we've
got nothing that time
you know and then another time there are
days when you're like
oh they were so articulate that day or
this crazy thing happened
so at the moment i'm assembling the
jigsaw pieces and then
probably in two months i start to put
the jigsaw pieces together so i'll
i'll have some i'll like index it and
i'd be like all right okay so
he talked about his childhood in hawaii
this time that time that
okay then you put all that together and
then you go oh okay this is this is
where he described
gambling all right okay so you're trying
to piece it all together slowly over
time
be to do that you've got to initially
immerse yourself in the actual
place and go back a lot and build up a
huge
reservoir of just stuff and
the other thing and this was hard for me
because i was a newspaper journalist for
a long time where
you know everything had to be
you know you've got 24 hours to write it
you don't have time for dead ends
you have to have a high tolerance for
dead ends so for every expert i've
quoted to you i need to be 10 experts
who were decent people and told me
nothing i used in the book right there's
a great uh
i know absolutely nothing about nature
so this could be [ __ ] but there's a
metaphor that thoreau the american
19th century american writer used where
he said
um apparently if you want to find a
beehive and you don't know where the
beehive is if you stay in a place and
wait for a bee to come along
and catch it in a jar just keep it there
for a couple of minutes
it will fly off in the direction of the
hive so you let it go and you run
and it the b is faster than you will
then you stand
you follow it as far as you can and then
you wait there you catch another bee let
that one go
follow that and if you do that like 30
times you'll find the beehive right
i don't that's true but that's what
thoreau says um and i think of writing
as a bit like that
it's like you
you start with a subject it's really big
why are so many people depressed
you look for people who've talked about
an interesting way you go and talk to
all of them
and then at the end of every interview
you say who else should i talk to and
you're going to talk to all of them
and you say who else should i see and
you get this kind of growing concentric
circle until
sooner or later you find the person who
like vincent felitti i interview i can't
tell you how many people are interviewed
about childhood trauma
and depression many of whom you know
were nice people who told me nothing of
interest
and i forget who it was it was a chain
it was a chain through about five people
who said someone said
you should talk to vincent felitti who's
he went to san diego and you're like ah
this is this is the thing right and and
some of that can be
sometimes you're lucky i knew in chasing
the scream i want to tell the story of a
drug dealer
and i remember chino was the second drug
dealer i interviewed him to be the guy
in baltimore
and i remember chino uh first thing he
said to me
almost the very first thing was
i was conceived with my mother who was a
crack addict was raped by my dad who was
an nypd officer
and i was like tell me more and i never
looked for another drug dealer i was
like
she knows my person right and china is
an unusually incredible human being in
all sorts of ways
he's no longer a drug dealer he's um he
he
arrested no no he was arrested he was
wreckers but he uh
he now campaigns to end the war on drugs
and actually had
shut down the horrific spafford the
horrific youth detention center that he
was detained in he's a
completely incredible person but um yeah
so
sometimes you're lucky and you don't
have to do the long chain you just find
the right person very early
and sometimes you spend five years
finding the right person
but for me it's a the the fun is the
the journey right the part of the fun
sometimes it's the fun of getting an
answer
vincent felitti you're like oh i now
understand childhood drama and addiction
and depression but yes it's a long a
long journey but i
i i'm really lucky i just love you
sometimes you meet writers who go
it's agony it's agony and i always want
to go can't [ __ ] work in a call
center for a week and come back and tell
me how difficult
i'm not saying there aren't challenges
in writing there are but anyone who is a
writer a professional writer
whose attitude is not everyday thank
god i'm an atheist but metaphorically
thank
god i get to do this job i'm so lucky
that's got to be your default position
it's a it's an incredible
privilege to get to do it i know that
sounds hashtag blessed and wanky but
like it really is
like a great um to get to kind of
investigate
complicated things and try to find
answers and explain them to people
who need to know and there's a lot of
people who need to know the answers to
these questions it's a great thing
but that's clearly why you've written so
many great books because you have
a intrinsic
joy for your work because the lengths
you've described there
ten years five years three years the air
miles you must have done to write these
books there's a whole part of greenland
that has melted because
there you go yeah i i i i'm not
going to [ __ ] i finish i wrote my
book um
over the space of a year and a half but
i
wouldn't have done what you did i i and
and that speaks to where my intrinsic
motivations and joy comes from
i enjoyed the process of writing the
book but the thoroughness that you put
into your books is just
staggering to me because i don't share
that intrinsic joy for the process which
you clearly do
um but you have a lot of intrinsic joy
for the other things that you yeah
exactly
important it's a shame it's just shame
to some degree i think part of my
conditioning of growing up in the social
media era where we get instant
gratification
made the the thought of you know when
i've got a
instant instagram story i can do or this
five-year book project but that's why i
really restrict i give you an example i
won't say his name but there's someone
a contemporary of mine a british writer
who's now based in the u.s who is
one of the cleverest people i know a
totally brilliant i mean just
politically
intellectually just an outstanding
person
and 10 years before if he'd been
exactly the same person 10 years before
he would have written
three brilliant books that changed how
people think about the subjects
and i've watched and it's been really
depressing
as he just atrophies his energy tweeting
all the time and he's got a huge twitter
following and i'm not saying that
doesn't do any good
it does sound good but and ever whenever
i see him i you know i mean
uh in the cities and i would say he he
you know we i
see him and he's just adult and you know
there's a line um
and ginsburg the poet said uh i saw the
best minds of my generation consumed by
madness
i feel like i saw the best minds of my
generation consumed by twitter
just [ __ ] i'm not saying there's no
value in it but
atrophying that energy and i've been
there right um years ago but
and so for me you're right a huge part
of writing a book
is deferred gratification i've gotta
interview people
for this biography for example i'm
writing noam chomsky he's an incredible
person
i interviewed someone two days ago
knowing i'm not gonna look at that
transcript
for seven years right and knowing
somewhere down the line i'm going to be
glad
i did that interview because that person
is quite old and they'll be dead if i
wait seven years and
you know and so you've got to be it's
very hard to defer gratification if you
can get an immediate hit
of but it's a very shallow hit right
when i meet people and i quite feel
difference right
sometimes people come up to me in the
street and they go uh i follow you on
instagram or whatever and there's and
it's a very shallow connection
and sometimes people come up to me and
they'll say i read your book
and they will even their physical
demeanor is different it's like being
approached by someone
who is a friend right and they will
always have some not always but most of
the time have some
much more detailed story i always feel
like i feel like if someone follows you
on twitter it's the equivalent
of shouting to you across a crowded bar
whistling exactly
whereas if you're lucky whistling i'm
slightly throwing the pint at you and
glassing you but
whereas if someone's read my book i feel
like i've gone on holiday with them
right the level of kind of intimate
because it takes a long time to read a
book right deeply personal
it's very and they've been in your head
right they've been injured childhood
yeah they've been and they've and
they've been on this if they remember
it's
a really big journey right so
there's an intimacy to that so i think
it's it's worth
it comes back to what you're saying
about porn right you could spend your
whole life sitting at home wanking over
porn
right i'm not against porn right i look
at it myself but
sometimes but we all know the hard work
of having a relationship
is ultimately going to be more
satisfying than your whole life one can
overpower
right speak for yourself exactly okay
very
and i feel like a lot of life is on that
principle right like
of course you can to me the people i
know
i mean i know who look who are tweeting
all the time and i know a lot of people
with really big twitter followings
it's not just that they partly it's
their atrophying their lives on
[ __ ] also it makes them really
[ __ ] unhappy
i know someone i won't say who but
someone who's got a very big twitter
following
who's got an ex it's a bit like our
instagram inspired so we're talking
about before
huge instagram photos sort of huge
twitter following
bumped into in the street a good few
years ago now
again like miserable as [ __ ]
right and made more miserable by i mean
i think about someone i know this is not
a famous person someone i know who
uses a uses a lot of meth
and is on twitter all the time and
genuinely if you said to me should this
individual quit twitter or meth
first i would say quit twitter it's
worse for him right
i don't mean that as a glib joke not
that meth is so great but it it
it just has such a negative effect on
people the thing i
dislike most about it is
for me um
[Music]
almost everything about being an
effective person in the world
is about being sincere and open-hearted
you know with humor and comedy and all
that stuff but you want to be
sincere and open-ended and what i don't
like about church and i think again it's
one things i feel happening to me as i
look at it
is the voice of twitter the kind of
generic voice
is you are sarcastic you're cold
you're one-upmanship a one-upmanship all
of these
things that are antithetical to
just a good life right if you want to
succeed on if you want to win at twitter
and i've seen this happen to so many
people i know um
how do you do it be sassy be nasty
be maximally judgmental there's no
tweets and going oh this person's
screwed up but
we all screw up sometimes let's you know
let's forgive the person to move on
there's no tweets in that
all the tweets are in kill the person
destroy them escalating outrage because
of the algorithms because the way they
work
um binary exactly just
it's not a forum it's a forum that
promotes
unkindness and aggressive certainty when
almost everything in life
that's meaningful comes from kindness
doubt listening to people also
encourages people to respond to
different
to me the worst possible way to go
through life
is to inc and again this is a big lesson
for me
i think about chasing the screams person
is a good example i can say
worst way to go through life is to meet
people who are different to you
and say that they're terrible and
condemn them
right to me that almost all the pleasure
in life is encountering people
encountering people who are different
and listening to them and think oh this
person's different to me that's really
interesting i think about someone
when people i most admire in the world
is a woman called christina dent
who read chasing the screams which is
why she got in touch with me
so christina is an evangelical christian
in mississippi who's a republican
right pretty different to me i'm a gay
atheist who
hates republicans right and christina
um so christina
is very opposed to abortion and she put
her money where her mouth is
she believes that if you're going to say
that women shouldn't have abortions
you've got to help them look after the
children that are then produced
so she fosters a lot of um children
in mississippi and if you foster
children in mississippi you know most of
the kids who get taken away from their
parents
their parents have addiction problems so
christina gets to know lots of women
with addiction problems the mothers are
the kids she's fostering
and because christine is a fundamentally
kind and good person
she's just like she starts thinking why
did no one help these mothers
years ago why are they criminalized why
are they put in prison and
denied access to public housing and all
of these things someone should have
helped them so she starts learning a lot
about drug policy one of the ways was
through
reading my book chasing the screen and
she set up a group called end it for
good
that is evangelical christians in
mississippi who are campaigning to end
the drug war
right and i got to know christina well
she's an amazing person and i think if i
had ever interacted with christina on
twitter if i got to know her through
twitter
we would hate each other right we would
look like diametrically opposed people
in fact she's a friend of mine i love
her she's a
fundament i mean really a deeply
admirable person right
often that that kind of connection can't
happen through
anger-fueled algorithms it can only
happen in fact angerfield
algorithms will destroy those
connections right and so i used to
remember what was it that happened
something happened with theresa may
who i'm sure you can guess i was not
politically sympathetic to
and i was about to tweet something nasty
about her
and i knew it would do well on twitter
i'm trying to remember what this was it
wasn't when she resigned it was before
that
i was about to tweet it and i just
thought i don't want to be part of this
[ __ ] machine
do i part this even someone who deserves
to be criticized as i believe you know
powerful all powerful people deserve to
have criticism and i think theresa may
deserved a lot of criticism because i
disagree with a lot of things she did
but she thought what is this adding to
the world other than more
spite and more anger and more cruelty
there are ways to oppose harmful things
that are not cruel and angry and and i
just see
so many people that i've known for years
you know senior media people who i just
feel have been poisoned by these ways of
interaction it's made them
cruel and i don't see any superiority i
was crawl when i was
heavily using these sites it's made them
cruel
and mean and petty and and and
worst of all i'm persuasive yeah
you know when i see people because i
think i won't name the person but i
think if someone is one of the most
followed
uh political people on twitter in
britain boris johnson no no no no uh
kirsten i'm not gonna go through it but
not a politician but someone who's a
publicly political person who i knew
god 15 years ago who was a
thoughtful interesting person when i met
them and is now just
cuddled with uh anger and
when i met this person you could have
sat them down with any ordinary british
person
they would talk about politics and they
would have thought about what he said
you know
they wouldn't always have agreed but it
would have been thoughtful now
he could talk to maybe five percent of
the british population who would fire up
to share the anger he has and 95 just be
like what is this this is just so
aggressive and hyperbolic and over the
top
and i don't blame this individual it's
not his fault
you've got a step away from these things
you
what i don't think you can do is be in
the middle of it be looking at it all
the time
and not be made crude or meaner by it i
just don't think you can i do think we
can change the algorithms in ways that
would mean that we wouldn't have to be
like that
but we're a long way off that right so
for me
if someone's listening to this now and i
had to ask you the very binary question
should they delete their twitter
instagram
or not in the so we're always encouraged
to think in these d
and it's perfectly good question but
we're always encouraged to think in
these deeply individualistic
ways right it's a bit like think about
global warming biggest crisis in the
world
terrible disaster right um and we're
always encouraged to think
uh global warming's so bad should i
personally
recycle more should i personally buy
this and not that
and the truth is your individual
consumer choices make no [ __ ]
difference to global warming
what you have no virtually no power as a
consumer
what you have is a huge amount of power
as a citizen right
we've got to if we band together as
citizens enough of us and demand that
everyone has to do certain things that
are necessary to stop
to to deal with the climate crisis then
you have power and agency
you personally tweaking your individual
behavior i mean don't do grossly harmful
things and i feel
we mentioned my own flying that's
obviously a harmful thing i i never fly
just to go on holiday but i do fly a lot
to go
to research my books and that is a a big
burden but
it's much more meaningful to focus on
collective activity so
if people want to think about the harm
that twitter does the heart that
facebook does i would say go to the
website at the center for humane
technology run by my friend tristana
harris
which is about putting pressure on the
truth is my friend james williams who's
a former google engineer brilliant guy
lives in moscow
he always says talking about you know
should i individually delete these
things it's like thinking the solution
to air pollution is should i put on a
gas mask
well all right if the air pollution is
really bad in beijing you might want to
put on a gas mask
but a much better thing to do is to you
know as citizens demand we deal with the
sources of air pollution right which can
be dealt with
in a similar way deleting your twitter
may well be a good thing to do i don't
use i don't ever look at twitter
almost never i use go through buffer app
but that's the equivalent of me putting
on a gas mask it gives me a very
short-term
personal uh protection but if i then go
out into a society
where people are being made angrier more
politically extreme
having their attention destroyed because
they're all on this stuff me putting on
my own [ __ ] gas mask
it's worth doing i'm glad to protect
myself but that's not where we should
start
thinking about it right but if i'm a
selfish bastard and i want to be happier
should i delete my instagram and my
facebook and my twitter i must i don't
give a [ __ ] about everybody else this is
me being you know
just pretending um i just want to make
sure that my life is more peaceful
less chance of depression less chance of
anxiety should i delete
twitter and facebook and instagram i
mean i personally would say
you know i mean i have it because i'm a
crudely because i
want to reach people with my messages um
you know and there's a mixture of that
some of that is the kind of benevolent
thing i think these things are important
and people need to know about and some
of that is a
more junk values uh i want to sell my
books right
but um
i don't feel i could tell an individual
they have to make their own assessment
what do they what do they get out of it
maybe they're you know promoting their
charity or whatever i don't know
that's all following kim kardashian
i mean what i would say is know that it
comes with a huge cost
now you only you can weigh is the
benefit
worth this huge cost yeah and there's
some people who for whom it will be
right and there's many people for whom
it won't be
but i would say the constant focus on
individualism even if you're purely
selfish
to me it's a bit like okay imagine we
were having this conversation in 1937
and we're really worried about the rise
of the nazis yeah
uh and people who worried about the rise
of the nazis let's imagine they were
saying
well i'm signing a pledge saying i
personally will not invade poland
right that's very nice i'm glad you're
not going to invade poland
but someone's going to go and have to
stop the people who are going to invade
poland yeah yeah in a similar way
fine say i'm not going to participate in
these hateful anger field agreements
good good for you
just like you shouldn't invade poland
but someone's going to have to stop the
people who are polluting the society and
[ __ ] us all
up which doesn't mean shutting down
facebook and twitter it means uh
changing their business model um which
absolutely can be done
i mean as james williams always says the
google engineer i was talking about
um the acts existed
for more i'm gonna get this wrong the
axe existed for more than a hundred
thousand years before anyone thought to
put a handle on it
um the internet has existed for less
than 10 000 days sure but we can change
these things if we want to
it comes back to so many things we're
talking about people need to know
that they have power you are so much
more powerful than you think
as a citizen incredible changes can
happen
when enough people persuade the people
around them
right and and do it in a spirit of love
and compassion
i think that's the perfect way to end
this conversation hooray
optimism exactly well and it's not even
like a kind of airy theory at all let's
be honest
it's true it's very practical margaret
mead the anthropologist said
never doubt that a small group of
committed citizens can change the world
it's the only thing that ever has it
reminds me of um
watching martin luther king's last
speech where he said to this huge black
congregation
on this stage he said um he was telling
he said i'm like
you know will you guys get there you
guys get to the mountaintop he goes i
don't get there with you
but you guys get there and at that time
you never would have imagined that
america could
make the progress it's made to as you
said to the point where it's got a black
president now and
when he said those words it sounded like
you know wishful thinking or whatever
but obviously the world um
to some degree you know last couple
years haven't been the best you know
example of that but
we got there well progress is possible
there's obviously still a long way to go
on
as you know much better and i don't want
racism and all sorts of things but
huge amount of progress is possible and
we must never
we've got to never discount the progress
that's been made because that's very
disempowering
actually you know i remember uh you know
even just things as simple as
of course we've got a huge way to go on
gender but i think about my
grandmother's right
that's not some distant past i know my
grandmothers
i loved my grandmothers i knew them well
obviously um
when they were the age i am now my
grandmothers were not allowed to have
bank accounts in their own names
my swiss grandmother um wasn't allowed
to have a job outside the home without
her husband's
written permission he could legally beat
her he could legally rape her he didn't
but
he could in fact it was legal for men to
rape their wives
everywhere in the world when my
grandmothers were the age i am now
there were no women leaders there were
no women leaders of companies
there were no women leaders of countries
um there were almost no women elected
representatives right this is not some
distant past
and i know we've got a lot and it's very
aggravating for women to hear a man like
me
mansplain this i get that um but and
because especially because we've still
got so much further to go but
you gotta always bear in mind the
incredible progress that happened and
how did that happen right
women didn't blow anything up they
didn't you know uh
tear the society down they they they
banded together and they fought for
something better i mean my great my
swiss grandmother didn't even have the
vote
when she was 42 years old right and my
scottish grandmother had a
[ __ ] hard life right incredible
transformations and changes are are
possible
we need to seize the power that we have
because we were talking before we live
in a machine that's designed
to get us neglect to neglect what's
important about life we also live in a
machine that's designed to make us think
we are not powerful
a machine that's designed to make us
think we can't change things
or the only mechanism to change things
is to change the way you shop
right and there's some value in changing
the way you shop but um
pick up the power you have right as
citizens you have we have incredible
power
we are all better off because of the
power the
previous generations have seized you
know think about you know
i'm gay you're black think about what
the lives just two generations back
again black people were in this country
they were a lot grimmer than our lives
right um
so incredible changes are possible we
just need to fight for them
thank you i always say thank you to my
guest at the end of the podcast for
various reasons but
obviously and i know it probably makes
you feel uncomfortable because i just
repeatedly blow smoke up your ass but
um the uh you know you can literally
bless no no
not with the cameras but the effort you
go to
to put this work together is just like
outstanding right and there's so much as
we've discussed there's so much like
there's such a lack of patience and a
superficial nature to the society we
live in and
people want instant gratification but
the delaying of the gratification and
doing the hard work
i i just you know it's just a tremendous
service that you're doing to
our society at a time that needs it the
most and especially the topics in which
you're
sticking your finger into and poking to
understand
our topics that are at the very heart of
much of our sort of social problems and
um it also present much of the
opportunities if we find the right
answers so thank you you've taught me a
ton
i can't wait for your new book right
when people ask me at any point in my
life they asked me to recommend a book i
always say lost connections because it
was that transformative and
um yeah um and what's your twitter
handle all right
what's my snapchat my publishers give me
this [ __ ] horrendous blurb please
knock it out but i meant to say if
anyone wants to know where to get the
audio book or the book
then go to um for the depression book
www.thelostconnections.com because it
turned out there was a [ __ ] band
called lost connections
who knew and the uh
um and the addiction book is chasing the
scream as in
dot com uh and they on those websites
you can find out where to follow me
everywhere except snapchat
because i'm strongly opposed to so and
your new book's coming soon
and soon yeah i can't wait [ __ ] me
that's going to be amazing and people
can uh also watch the
film adaptation of chasing the screen
which i meant to plug the oscar
nominated film adaptation
uh which is called the united states
versus billie holiday and is where do we
go
in britain on sky cinema in the us on
hulu
and you should interview andrea who
played billy holliday who is
beyond a goddess and a [ __ ]
incredible person
lure her i'll give you an intro she's
she was nominated for the skirt did not
get it
i am the true victim of covered because
i would have been in the oscars
as one of the producers and i was gutted
that didn't happen anyway
plenty of time there for you for that to
happen exactly no one suffered in covey
mode
thank you so much anne cheers thanks so
much i really appreciate it
[Music]
[Music]